the 45th president of the united states
of america
president donald trump
but i got to tell you matt and corky and
i and all of you
are here for one reason and one reason
only
and that is that new hampshire and
america
need four more years of president donald
trump in the white house
and the road to victory goes right
through new hampshire
it's on everybody it really is great to
be here
and it really all kind of began here in
new hampshire
not only are they you the first in the
nation primary but you were the first
primary that said yes to president
donald trump
in new hampshire you knew we could be
strong again
you knew we could be prosperous again
you knew america could be standing tall
at home and abroad again you said yes in
that first in the nation primary to
president donald trump
in 2016. and i know new hampshire is
going to say yes to president donald
trump in 2020.
you know the president is headed off to
north carolina today but
tomorrow night he's going to take the
stage
in the final presidential debate with
joe biden in nashville tennessee and i
can't wait
you know we had a little debate of our
own over in salt lake city a couple
weeks back
thank you some people think we did all
right
thank you but i got to tell you it was a
great privilege for me to be on that
stage
talking about all that we accomplished
with this president in the white house
over the last four years
and think about where we started four
years ago we inherited a military that
was hollowed out by devastating budget
cuts
our economy was recovering from the
slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression
terrorism was on the rise around the
world
and we'd witnessed a steady assault on
our most cherished values
but in three short years we rebuild our
military
we revived the american economy we
secured
our border supported law enforcement
stood for life
liberty and the constitution of the
united states of america
it's been america first
and america first all starts with the
national defense
you know when we took office we'd seen
years of reckless budget cuts to our
national defense
when joe biden was vice president of the
united states
president donald trump he actually
signed the largest investment in our
national defense since the days of
ronald reagan i have to tell you
not just as your vice president but as
the proud father of a united states
marine and the father-in-law of a united
states navy pilot
i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president
who has fought every day to give our men
and women
of our armed forces the resources and
the support that they need
to defend this nation we're doing it
we've rebuilt our military we haven't
just stood with those who
haven't just stood with those who wear
the uniform we've stood with those
who've worn the uniform of the united
states
i mean are there veterans in the
audience today could you put your hand
or your hat in the air just
give us a chance to say thank you one
more time
thank you for your service
thank you for your service
it's amazing to think when we took
office
we go through years of scandals at the
va you all remember here in new
hampshire
joe biden was vice president we
literally had
veterans who were perishing waiting to
receive
treatment at va hospitals when president
donald trump
walked into the oval office everything
changed
we passed the most sweeping reforms of
the va in
50 years we fired thousands of va
employees
that were not giving our veterans the
care that they earned
in the uniform of the united states and
veterans choice is now available for
every veteran in america
so we stood strong with those who serve
and we've sit strong with those
who did so and all along the way
president donald trump revived our
economy with the time-honored principles
of freedom
free markets and free enterprise and
after the slowest recovery
since the great depression we created
the greatest economy in american history
it's amazing to think when joe biden was
vice president they tried to tax
and spend and bail and regulate their
way back to a growing economy you
remember those things
i mean the american economy recovered in
spite
of the policies of the obama
administration
and now in the midst of a global
pandemic joe biden wants to raise taxes
by four trillion dollars
just at a time that america is coming
back
president trump we cut taxes across
the board for working families and
businesses large and small
we rolled back more federal red tape
than any administration
in history we fought for free and fair
trade that put america first
we unleashed american energy and in just
three short years
seven million jobs were created by
businesses large and small
including 19 000 jobs right here in the
granite state
i mean i'm proud to report to you under
president trump's policies and
leadership
average hourly earnings grew faster in
our first
three years than in all eight years
when joe biden was vice president
and wages rose most rapidly for
hard-working blue-collar
americans the forgotten men and women of
america were forgotten no more
you know and on health care you all
remember the disaster of obamacare
remember the big three promises they
said if you like your doctor you can
keep
that wasn't true they said if you like
your health insurance you can keep it
that wasn't true they said health
insurance premiums would go down
you know when we took office health
insurance premiums had actually
doubled in the wake of obamacare and now
joe biden wants to double down on the
failed policies of obamacare
he and kamala harris actually support
adding a public
option to obamacare straight out of
bernie sanders agenda
it'll set us on an inevitable path to
socialize medicine
but under president donald trump
we're going to keep lowering the cost of
health insurance without growing the
size of government we've lowered the
cost of prescription
drugs we passed right to try
we're going to have the best health care
in the world
and we will never be a socialist country
so it's been about jobs it's been about
prosperity rolling back
red tape giving the american people a
health care system built on the
principles of free enterprise
when it comes to economic policy our
international trade here in new
hampshire and all across
america is vitally important the truth
is
when we took office half of our
international trade deficit
was with communist china joe biden's
been a cheerleader for communist china
all along the way and closer to home
in the decades that followed the passage
of nafta remember democrats always used
to like to talk about
everything that was wrong with nafta but
joe biden never lifted a finger to
reform nafta as literally
thousands of factories closed across the
country
and those jobs were shipped south of the
border and overseas
it's amazing to think after all those
empty promises and all those failed
policies
president trump stepped into the oval
office we put china on notice
we said the era of economic surrender is
over
we impose tariffs on china and we'll
keep standing strong on china until they
open their markets to american goods
and protect the private property rights
of american enterprise
and on nafta the guy that wrote the art
of the deal got america
a great deal nafta is gone the usmca
is now the law of the land
and energy is a critical part it's a
critical part
of family budgets and business budgets
and a growing economy
you all in new hampshire deserve to know
joe biden and the radical left
want to crush american energy under a
two trillion dollar version of the green
new deal
it would literally raise the cost of
electricity for every household and
every business
in new hampshire i mean it's incredible
when you think about it
i mean president trump actually had to
remind joe biden in that last
presidential debate that he supported
the green new deal
but i gotta tell you very much
difference between aoc
green new deal and joe biden and kamala
harris's great new deal
and that's just how usa today identified
i mean the truth is joe biden is talking
about
mandates out of washington dc that would
stifle american jobs and economies
he said he wants to abolish fossil fuels
in this country
under president donald trump we've
unleashed american energy
and under the policies of this president
we've developed the vast natural
resources
of this nation and we're now a net
exporter of energy
for the first time in 70 years
now when joe biden was vice president
you all might remember america actually
lost
200 000 manufacturing jobs
remember the last president that
summertime in 2016.
i heard he's in philadelphia today but
he probably won't bring this up so i
will
the last president actually said that
those manufacturing jobs in america were
never coming back
200 000 were gone for good right
i mean from you know i'm from out in the
heartland and these people like calling
our neck to the woods the rust belt and
there was a lot of rust on the belt when
they were in charge
right remember barack obama said what
magic
wand do you have well we didn't need a
magic wand
we just needed president donald trump in
the white house
500 000 manufacturing jobs created
in just three years including 3 000
right here in new hampshire
i mean it's just incredible when you
think about the progress that we've made
this president's been a champion all
along the way of american jobs
and american workers as i stand before
you today men and women we have a choice
to make
a truth in this election
come november 3rd it's going to be a
choice between a trump recovery and
abiding depression
i mean just yesterday a nonpartisan
study came out that said under joe
biden's economic policies
america would lose 5 million jobs
and the average household income in
america in the coming years would drop
by six thousand five hundred dollars a
year
it's no real surprise when you're gonna
raise taxes by four trillion dollars
where you're gonna drop a
two trillion dollar version of the green
new deal on top
of the american economy when you're
talking about
driving out and abolishing american
energy and going back to economic
surrender it's no surprise
i mean in every day between now and
election day you gotta you gotta ask
yourself your neighbors and your friends
of
worship and at work i mean who do you
really think is gonna bring this economy
all the way back
is it a proven job creator that put
timeless free market principles into
practice
and saw seven million jobs created or a
career politician
who spent 47 years in washington raising
taxes stifling our economy under an
avalanche of regulation and economic
surrender
so men and women in new hampshire for
our families
for our jobs for our economic freedom
and the american comeback we need four
more years of president donald trump in
the white house
so it's been about security it's been
about prosperity
you fought for american energy and
american workers and every step of the
way president donald trump has stood
for the rule of law i'm proud to report
to you but as i stand here today
this president's appointed more than 200
conservatives to our federal courts at
every level
and they are all men and women who will
uphold the god-given liberties enshrined
in our constitution like the freedom of
religion
the freedom of speech and the second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
and i'll tell you what we'll always
defend the freedom of speech
and the freedom of the press at a time
when big tech
is actually trying to censor what
americans read or see
or say
we're going to take a stand
you all might have seen yesterday the
justice department launched an
anti-trust lawsuit
against google
while big tech is trying to protect joe
biden
president donald trump and i will always
fight to protect your freedom of speech
we're not gonna let big tech block the
truth not now not ever
when you think of the rule of we think
of
law
month we paused as a nation
to rightly honor the life and service of
the late justice ruth bader ginsburg
but when the memorials were over
president trump fulfilled his
constitutional duty
and he nominated a remarkable
brilliant principal conservative
woman who loves the constitution to the
supreme court of the united states he
nominated judge
amy coney barrett
isn't she great
now the president and i are calling on
democrats to
give judge barrett a respectful and
dignified confirmation
but we have reason to be concerned and
you all remember a couple years ago
during her last confirmation to the
court of appeals
the leading democrat on the judiciary
committee actually criticized judge
barrett's catholic faith
she said it was a concern saying and i
quote
the dogma lives loudly within you
and hollywood elites have already begun
to criticize judge barrett's faith
but i got news for the democrats and
their friends in hollywood
that dogma lives loudly in me
that dogma lives loudly in you
and the freedom to live to work to
worship
according to the dictates of our faith
lives loudly in the constitution of the
united states
of america
that's who we are it's our freedom
so the senate's got a job to do and
after they discharge their duty
this week and early next we advise and
consent i'll make you predictions
judge amy coney barrett is going to be
justice
amy coney barrett we're gonna fill that
seat
on the supreme court of the united
states
now while we're talking about supreme
court
people here in this freedom-loving state
deserve to know
after 150 years with nine justices on
the supreme court of the united states
leading democrats in washington are
actually talking about packing the court
adding seats to the court so they can
appoint liberal activist judges to drive
their agenda from the judicial mind
i mean last saturday last thursday night
joe biden said in this town hall that
he's quote
open to considering packing the court
kamala harris said in the primary she
was quote absolutely open
and when i when i asked her during the
vice presidential debate what the answer
was she refused to give me a straight
answer
now joe biden is telling the american
people
he'll tell us what he's going to do
after judge barrett is confirmed
next week even though millions of
americans are voting right now
i mean come on man
the american people deserve a straight
answer
when you're running for the highest
office in the land
you gotta tell america whether you
respect the highest court in the land
am i right
i mean come on you know i was born in
the morning but not yesterday morning
we all know the answer joe biden and
kamala harris aren't answering the
question because
we already know the answer joe biden
democratic party and the radical left
we're going to pack the court
with liberal activist judges if they win
this election
but we're not gonna let it happen we're
gonna re-elect a republican majority in
the senate
and we're gonna re-elect president
donald trump for four more years
the stakes are just that high men and
women
hacking the court like these democrats
are planning to do that be the greatest
power grab in american history
we've got to talk to our neighbors and
friends about it and about the states
i mean it's just one more reason by
right after you reelect president donald
trump
you've got to send corky messner to the
united states senate
corki messner
flores a wonderful african-american
business owner
started that salon in minneapolis 35
years ago it became a
centerpiece of the community and she
told me the story about
just days after the killing of george
floyd how she saw the violent protesters
come
closer and closer and closer to her
business until the night
they burned her up
men and women i'm going to tell you
i told flora that day we're going to
rebuild
we're going to rebuild bigger and better
than ever before and we're going to have
law
and order for her and for every american
in every city of every race and creed
and color
so help us god
i mean the truth is joe biden would
double down on the policies that
are leading to violence in our major
cities
when you start to erode support
for those who protect and serve our
families
you just embolden those who would do
violence
for those we love and to our community
now joe biden explains it all by saying
that america is in his words
systemically racist
and he and his running mate repeatedly
say that police officers have a quote
implicit bias against minorities
when he was asked if he'd support
cutting funding for law enforcement joe
biden said
yes absolutely and his running mate
kamala harris actually praised the mayor
of los
angeles for cutting 150 million dollars
out of the budget of the lapd
let me make your promise under president
donald trump
we're not going to defund the police not
now not
ever we're going to back the blue for
four more years
i mean the president i know what you all
know
we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement and
supporting our african-american
neighbors
and friends and minorities and everyone
that lives in our cities
i mean i couldn't be more proud to be a
vice president to a president who
supported funding for
the hiring of 4 000 new police officers
when violence outbreak that broke out
this summer
we literally searched federal officials
in operation legend
every major city in the country and
we've arrested nearly 3
000 violent offenders already restoring
peace to our streets
but at the same time in that same period
of time
because of this president's policies we
saw the lowest unemployment ever
recorded for african americans we
created more than 8
000 opportunity zones for inner city
families
we signed historically black colleges
universities their largest
budgets ever and made them permanent
and we have fought for educational
choice for every family in every city in
america
so i promise you we're going to keep
supporting law enforcement
we're going to keep supporting our
african-american neighbors
with more jobs more opportunities better
education more public safety
and we're going to do it all for four
more years
so we stood for the rule of law stood
with those who defend
our families at home and abroad
when it comes to values i couldn't be
more proud to serve alongside a
president who has stood for the
religious freedom
of every american of every faith every
single day
president donald trump is the greatest
champion of people of faith in america
in my lifetime
and i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president who stands without
apology
for the sanctity of human life
you all deserve to know that joe biden
and kamala harris actually support
taxpayer funding of abortion
all the way up to the moment of birth
they're calling for a historic increases
to planned parenthood of america
and they want to restore funding to
promote abortion
around the world but i promise you
president donald trump is the most
pro-life president in american history
and we're going to stand
for the right to life for four more
[Music]
years
so in our first three years amazing to
think what we all accomplished
we rebuilt our military we revived our
economy we stood for law and order
liberties
and life and that's why
that's why we need to not only reelect
president donald trump for four more
years
not only send corey messner to the
united states senate
but we need to send matt mowers to a new
republican majority in the united states
house of representatives
and retired nancy pelosi once and for
all
hey when you look at what we were able
to accomplish when we had republican
majorities in the house and the senate
men and women in new hampshire you know
the job before
it's amazing to think in three short
years
president in the white house with our
allies in the house and the senate
only one way you can describe it
in three short years we made america
great again
right we just did
and then 2020 hit
the corona virus struck from china
but i can tell you firsthand before the
first documented case of community
spread in the united states
president trump did what no american
president had ever done before
he suspended all travel from china the
second largest economy
in the world
now joe biden said that was xenophobic
he said it was hysterical he actually
wrote a few days earlier that that
banning travel from anywhere in the
world
would actually make things worse
but i can tell you joe biden's wrong
as head of the white house coronavirus
task force i can
i can attest firsthand
president trump's decision to suspend
all travel from
china saved untold american lives
and it bought us invaluable time to
stand up the greatest national
mobilization since world war ii
we reinvented testing we saw to the
manufacturer in the distribution of
billions of supplies
we've created new medicines called
therapeutics that are literally saving
lives every single day
and we're just a matter of weeks away
from having the first safe and effective
coronavirus vaccine
and tens of millions of doses available
for the american people
that's what leadership looks like
in fact the president just announced
last week a plan with cvs and walgreens
to deliver and administer vaccines to
our seniors
in nursing homes for free all across
america the moment it becomes available
i mean with the incredible cooperation
of the people of this state and this
country
putting the health of your families and
neighbors first
with our incredible doctors and nurses
health care providers and first
responders
with partnership at the state level and
the leadership with this president
we're protecting the vulnerable we've
given the american people everything we
need to make sure that anyone impacted
by the coronavirus
has the support to get the health care
that we want any member of our family to
have
and we're saving lives
and where joe biden is talking about
shutting down the economy
we're opening up america again
i mean in just the last five months
after losing 22 million jobs at the
height of this pandemic
with that strong foundation that
president trump poured with your support
in our first three years
with the unprecedented relief and
recovery efforts
four trillion dollars made available to
families and businesses
we've already seen eleven and a half
million americans go back
to work including 61 000 people right
here in new hampshire
we're opening up america and we're
opening up america's schools
i'm proud to report to you mr pence is
already back in the classroom
teaching at a little christian school
just outside our nation's country
so we're going to keep those supplies
rolling until the day comes that we have
that vaccine and we can
put this coronavirus in the past for all
the progress we've made it's a testament
to our president's leadership
an incredible free enterprise system
great research companies great doctors
and nurses
let me also say it is a testament here
in new hampshire
the strong and compassionate leadership
of governor chris
sununu
so we're moving our country forward
we've gone through a time of testing
but in just 13 days we're going to come
to a time for choosing
which is why i'm out here and you're out
here in the drizzle today in new
hampshire
you know when you look at their agenda
higher taxes
open borders socialized medicine a green
new deal
defunding the police packing the courts
it's clear joe biden would be nothing
more than a trojan horse for the radical
left
now joe biden says that democracy is on
the ballot
well i think our economic recovery is on
the ballot
i think law and order are on the ballot
but i think there are things much more
foundational
to our nation i think in this election
it's not so much whether we're going to
end up more republican or more democrat
more conservative or more liberal more
red or more blue
new hampshire the choice in this
election i believe is whether america
remains america
it's going to be a choice of whether we
build a future on all the timeless
principles and shrine
in that constitution benjamin franklin
walked out independence hall and he was
asked in 1787 what former government
they've created he said
a republic if you can keep
men and women i think this is a choice
such time as this
it's choice about whether we're going to
keep the republic it's whether we're
going to chart a course based on freedom
limited government the ideals and the
liberties and the principles enshrined
in our founding document
whether we're going to let joe biden and
the democratic party
take us on a path of american decline
so let me say for our freedom for our
republic
for all the ideals that have always made
america great
we need to decide right here and right
now
that joe biden will never be president
of the united states we're going to
re-elect
president donald trump for four more
[Music]
years
and with four more years as the
president says
we're gonna accomplish so much for this
country
with four more years we'll distribute a
vaccine and we'll defeat the virus
four more years we'll maintain america's
unrivaled military might
and ensure peace through american
strength
with four more years we'll make america
into the manufacturing superpower
of the world and end reliance on china
once and for
all we'll uphold religious liberty
freedom of speech the right
to keep and bear arms
we'll hire more police
we will ban sanctuary cities
we will stop the indoctrination of our
students and restore
patriotic education in our schools
and as president trump said that mount
rushmore
will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect our
great
american flag
and we'll live by those timeless words
national mind
your motto is live free or not
our motto is all of us is in god we
trust
now i got to tell you men and women in
new hampshire i'm just very grateful you
came out on a soggy day
to see your vice president
really very honored
i have to tell you it's the greatest
honor of my life to be your vice
president and i thank you for that great
honor
and for your support
you know i actually didn't know the
president very well before he called me
four years ago and asked me to join this
ticket but we've got to be very close
some people think we're a little bit
different
but i got to tell you i've seen this
president when all the cameras are off
when all the bright lights are off and i
can tell you firsthand
having served shoulder to shoulder with
him over these last four years
there has never been a day that
president donald
trump against unprecedented opposition
and attacks there has never been a day
president donald trump hasn't gotten up
and fought to keep the promises that he
made to the people of new hampshire
now it's our turn to fight for him
it's on new hampshire
it's on
so before i get back on that plane and
head to ohio i got a couple things to
ask of you
over the next 13 days first thing i need
you to do
is vote new hampshire vote to re-elect
president donald trump to the white
house
you know i heard the last day to
register before the election here in
portsmouth is going to be next wednesday
october 28th so if you're not registered
yet
go to the city clerk's office on one
junkins avenue
normal wednesday hours 8 a.m to 4
30. there's still time
if you're not registered to vote get
registered to vote today
in fact i checked out on the way here
you can go and request an absentee
ballot until election day you can mail
it in and drop it off at the very same
location
mr and aren't going to do that in the
hoosier state in just a couple days
so we need you to vote new hampshire and
remember friends don't let friends vote
alone
grab a family member grab a neighbor
grab a co-worker
and vote to reelect president donald
trump
okay so after you vote with a friend
second thing i want to ask you to do is
just go tell somebody
okay i mean i got i got to tell you
four years ago i never doubted
that this president was going to win in
that election and i don't doubt it today
because i know the american people then
and now we're talking to each other
i mean the people of this state knew we
could be strong again
you knew we could be prosperous again
you were talking to your neighbors and
friends about those timeless
ideals of this country and you saw in
donald trump
not just the vision but the leadership
qualities to make america great again
and so go tell your neighbors and
friends say you know i went out the
airport the other day it was raining and
mike came out he ran every bit as fast
as he could
and then he talked to us like for an
hour out in the rain
just about everything we've done about
the choice that we face
and about everything we can do for
america with four more years of
president donald trump
in the white house you got to go tell
them
so after you vote with a friend after
you tell your neighbors and friends
every day for the next
13 days i encourage you to do one more
thing
you know traveling all across this
country over the last four years i've
convinced you two things
in this live free or die state
this is a freedom-loving nation
and this is a nation of faith
i mean i had a little girl in that vice
presidential debate
turned in a question at the end where
she said she was watching tv and it just
looked like there was so much that
divides us
after traveling across america i'm more
convinced than ever there will always be
more that unites us
in these united states of america than
will ever divide us
and chief among those things is of faith
in the american people
and so if you're among those who on
occasion
bend the knee and bow the head over the
next 13 days i encourage you to do that
too
and when you pray
pray with confidence those ancient words
that
if his people who are called by his name
will humble themselves and pray and turn
that he'll do like he's always done in
the long and storied history of this
state
and nation he'll hear from heaven
and he'll heal this land
this one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice
for all so pray for america pray for all
of the american people it'll make a
difference new hampshire
so thanks again for coming out today you
all are just
you're like the greatest i can't wait to
get on the phone and tell them
i said you said your wingman was in new
hampshire and we were all out there
getting rained on and they
you all just been saying give yourselves
a round of applause for coming out on a
rainy day
thank you so much i leave here today
with renewed confidence
that if all of us do all that we need to
do between now
and november 3rd we're going to have a
great victory
across new hampshire and all across
america
because as this president often says
we're one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation
and i just know that together
we're going to make new hampshire and
america stronger than ever before
we're going to make new hampshire and
america more prosperous than you could
possibly imagine
we're going to make new hampshire and
america more united
than ever before
and with corey messner in a renewed
republican
majority in the united states senate
with matt mowers in a new republican
majority
in the house of representatives with
governor chris sununu back at the state
house and with president
donald trump in the white house for four
more years
and with god's help
we will make america great again
again thank you all very much
god bless you god bless america let's go
get it done new hampshire
oh
let's go
[Music]
dreams
yes
here
down
[Music]
[Music]
you